joining us now the Attorney General of
the United States Bill Barr mr. Attorney
General thanks for being here Thank You
Brad the effort across the country there
is this movement to defund Police
Department's the Minneapolis City
Council with a veto-proof vote saying
they're going to essentially dismantle
that Police Department what do you make
of that effort and what it means for the
country well I think it's the exact
opposite of the way we should go you
know I understand given the history of
racial injustice in this country why the
african-american American community or
at least some of it would view the
ghastly events in Minneapolis as
manifestations of institutional racism
and police departments but I think in
fact over the past 50 or 60 years we've
had a lot of reform of Police Department
I was Attorney General 30 years ago and
I can tell you there's a world of
difference today the police chief's the
rank-and-file officers understand the
need for change and there has been great
change and I think defunding the police
holding the entire police structure
responsible for the actions of certain
officers is wrong and I think it's
dangerous to demonize police but so how
do these bad cops if you want to call
them that get through in these systems
do you blame police unions do you blame
the systems themselves for not weeding
them out how do you address what
obviously is this frustration and anger
well not referring to any particular
case I think you have to remember this
is not a monolithic system there are
thousands of different police forces
there approximately 900,000 police
officers in the United States and right
now if there's a crisis in policing
because it's a very tough job we have
we had before Cova today full employment
economy and if anything we've had
trouble attracting people and retaining
people as police officers we want the
best most responsible people we can get
and we have to attract them into the
profession we have to retain them we
have to train them and we have to
continue to professionalize our police
forces we have generally speaking
excellent police forces in the United
States
none of us as individuals want to be
lumped together with us if we want to be
judged by what we do as individuals we
don't want misconduct of others
attributed to us and that's in every
walk of life you know one of the one of
the legitimate grievances of the African
American community is that they're
treated with suspicion and braced simply
because they're African Americans and
that doesn't happen by the same token
demonstrators peaceful demonstrators
shouldn't be treated as violent
extremists simply because they're out on
the streets it's the same with police
officers every organization has
individuals who engage in misconduct and
we have to be very careful before we say
the whole organization is robbed what
would happen if a major American city
Chicago DC disbanded its police
department what would that look like
well the federal government had to step
in well what it would look like is you
would have an increases in vigilantism
and you would have increasing chaos in
the city and that's why doing things
that prevent us from having a strong
effective police force are
counterproductive you'll end up having
more killings and that's been shown time
and time again but so a major American
city doing that you're saying would be
dangerous absolutely you know I think we
have to put things in perspective
obviously when police use excessive
force they have to be held accountable
and right here both the state and
federal government zoomed in and
immediately took up the matter there's
no question it's an issue and has to be
dealt with but in terms of sheer numbers
is it is that these police officers who
are pressing African American community
they're a lot more damaged a lot more
killing a lot more fear engendered on
the streets from criminal elements in
Chicago for example in one ich one
weekend you know 6070 people shot if you
pull back the police for these
communities they'll be they'll be more
harm done to these communities the
president you know has has been
attempting to address the criminal
justice reform issue he did the first
step back he set up the first Police
Commission since Lyndon Johnson and
we've been looking precisely at these
issues and we'll be coming out very
shortly with our proposals on this and
he's also advanced opportunity zones in
the inner city and he's pushing for
school choice for inner-city parents
that's it that's to me the civil rights
issue of our era is giving these parents
the wherewithal to educate their
children and the best school as possible
and and so he is addressing that I think
pulling the police back from these
communities would would would make it
far more difficult for these communities
to have the equal opportunity and the
full participation and the American
dream that they deserve as you know
there's a House bill an effort for
police reform from Congress it includes
a few things I'd like to get your
thoughts on it a national misconduct
register for police well I even looked
at the proposal so I'm not exactly sure
an issue of those right but you know an
issue-by-issue I think we have to be
there's a prudent balance to be struck
between making sure we can hold
wrongdoers accountable police is not
like sitting in an office you know
checking boxes we put these individuals
into highly charged dangerous situations
where their own life is at stake their
Adrenaline's pumping and so forth and we
have to make sure we treat them fairly
in those kinds of circumstances banning
choke holds I think we should ban choke
holds lateral choke holds except when
it's necessary to meet lethal you know
to unless police officers confronted
with potentially lethal force but I
think there's a general agreement among
police agencies that we need
clearer standards we have to make sure
those standards are cleaned - and we
have to make sure that there are systems
in place that hold officers accountable
I think there's a universal agreement on
that so is that a federal effort does
that suddenly become a federal training
effort I think we're going to need a
strong federal participation in this
effort in helping to set standards a lot
of talk about Monday kind of reliving
the moment there in Lafayette Park if
you had to do Monday over again would
you do something different based on what
I know now on Monday we were reacting to
three days of extremely violent
demonstrations right across from the
White House a lot of injuries to police
officers arson the things were so bad
that the Secret Service recommended the
president go down to the bunker we can't
have that in our country and so the
decision was made we had to move the
perimeter one block and that is what we
were doing did the president tell you
that he was planning on walking over to
the church no he didn't tell me I found
out later that afternoon that he might
go outside the what White House but as
I've said the decision to actually move
out the perimeter was was initially made
Sunday night by the Park Police in the
early morning hours on Monday when I
arrived I agreed with the general
conception of moving at the perimeter so
we could fortify in in the sense of a
stronger fencing and so forth Lafayette
Park and also gives it some breathing
space and that decision was a set in
execution at two o'clock with all the
police tactical chiefs but I mean seeing
what has come from it and the image that
has at least been perceived you wouldn't
do it differently
what what well the images has somewhat
been created and Mis created in the
sense that I haven't seen any videos on
TV of all the violence
that was happening proceeding and were
hit or something or thrown something was
thrown at you I did go to the park
before the actual operation to move out
the perimeter and I personally saw
projectiles thrown and two were thrown
at me and the police officers there and
my security detail made me move back
because they said that projectiles had
been landing in a certain area rock
things like rocks bottles thrown at me
you said you wouldn't do anything
differently but the perception of
clearing out the park understanding you
made the decision earlier and then the
president walking over even the visual
of kind of the group all white mostly
male it sent an image that a lot of
people jumped on and said that it wasn't
a good thing for the president in
retrospect I asked you would you do
anything differently would you do
anything differently on the even the
walk over to the church you were there
so was the defense secretary so it was
the chairman of the Joint Chiefs well
you know it's not it that was a decision
for the White House and the president to
make my decision that you asked me about
earlier was moving the perimeter one
block to provide greater security for
the White House and I would do the same
and I don't sit as a critic of you know
these kinds of leadership decisions made
at the White House but as I've said the
President of the United States should be
able to walk one block from the White
House out to the Church of presidents he
should be able to do that and and and
you know this canard that this exercise
was done to make that possible is
totally false I don't see anything wrong
with the president walking over to the
church the perception is that the
president was calling for I don't know
how many their numbers 10,000 but let's
say just thousands of active military
troops on the ground did you push back
on the use of the insurrection Act there
was no need to push back I think
everyone was on the same page I think
what we were discussing is what would be
necessary around the country and in DC
specifically and I think everyone agreed
that if it became necessary we could
resort to federal troops as a last
resort there's a lot of people that have
been charged with crimes related to the
protests that devolved into riots and
looting to my knowledge none of the
criminal complaints have mentioned an
Tifa why is that we have some
investigations underway and very focused
investigations on certain individuals
that relate to em Tifa but in the in the
initial phase of identifying people and
arresting them they were arrested for
crimes that don't require us to identify
a particular group or don't necessitate
that doesn t have leaders it's a very
loosely organized group and they have
sort of a unique or unusual system of
communication and organization there are
people who can be characterized as
leaders in any given situation
are there people funding this effort an
organized effort that it goes beyond
state specific that funding the effort
broadly and are you going over after
those people there appear to be sources
of funding and we
looking into the sources of funding and
there you know there is clearly some you
know high degree of organization
involved at some of these events and and
and coordinated tactics that we're
saying and we're looking into that as
well
and and some of it relates to empty feh
some of it relates to groups that act
very much like an teef there as I said
there's a witch's brew of extremist
groups that are trying to exploit this
situation on all sides when you look
back at covert 19 and what has happened
do you think we will conclude that
elected officials went too far in
shutting down society to the point of
trampling Americans fundamental
constitutional rights I think given the
uncertainty involved and the very fast
pace of the infection especially in
certain areas the original 30 day or so
or and even maybe with some extensions
measures were appropriate but I think
that as time has gone by the degree of
impingement on fundamental liberties has
never been anything like this in the
united states nationally forbidding
people from engaging in their livelihood
telling them to stay home is just sort
of a form of house arrest in many places
have these protests and demonstrations
and what we've seen across the country
changed that dynamic I think it should
because it raises a fundamental question
which is why should some people who are
enjoying their First Amendment rights by
going out and protesting have have
broader rights than other people who may
want to exercise their for example
religious First Amendment rights and go
to church as long as social distancing
rules and things like that are complied
with there's a report that the US has
officially demanded Britain hand over
Prince Andrew to be quizzed about his
links to the billionaire pedophile
Jeffrey Epstein is that true I don't
think it's cuz I'm handing him over I
think it's just a question of
having him provide some evidence but
beyond that I'm not going to comment so
extradition no just asking for evidence
evidence that case is still in process
you've commented on the death of Epstein
you're convinced that he committed
suicide
is there more to come from that
investigation into that there might be
more to come but I don't think anything
that would change that conclusion what's
your definition of law and order the
real task and framing a government is to
have a government that is capable of
governing strong enough to govern but
not so strong that it a bridging the
bridges the rights of the people and so
you have to have power but you also have
to have controls on that power in the
case of the government for example
excessive police force law and order
means that the government is bound by
law and people have to be accountable
for abusing their power this is
unprecedented to have a pandemic with
lockdowns
and then this event with protests across
the country we've never really seen
anything like it that's right I last
time I was a J which was not for that
long a period I had been deputy before
that someone showed me a list of all the
crises we handled at that time and I
thought wow it was a very eventful
period but nothing like we're seeing
today mr. Attorney General
thank you very much the time thank you I
appreciate it